>> GREGORIO: All right. Welcome. So good morning.
Welcome. I thought I found a really good hiding
spot for my talk. Apparently, you guys are
dedicated. So, my name is Joe Gregorio. I'm
a software engineer. I work on the infrastructure
side for and--the client side actually, for
the API infrastructure that Google uses to
deliver APIs, so. And we're here right--in
direction to Google APIs, as Tim mentioned,
in his keynote, this is the speaker meter
for this particular track, so if you want
to scan that. So, the talk's going to be,
just like it says, introduction to APIs. We're
going to go very slow. We're going over a
lot of the pieces that we have in place for
APIs. This is not the only talk going on about
Google APIs and adjunct to this talk is the
lab this afternoon, hands on with the Google
APIs where we'll be basically going over the
same exact talk but much slower and with a
lot of hands on in between, hands on working
with the tools and with some programming.
The write up is listed as Python. If you don't
know Python, do not be afraid to come. It's
very simple language. We're not doing a lot
of complex Python programming in that track,
so just that I pitch that session for later.
So, it's Boot Camp, let's dive right into
the code, okay. This is Python code. I don't
expect you to understand it. And by the end
of this talk, I don't really expect you to
understand it either. But, hopefully, you'll
have a better idea of what's going in the
code by the end of this talk and more importantly,
you will know where to go to learn the pieces
that you don't know. This is a, teach a person
to fish rather than giving them a fish type
of talk. So, hopefully by the end of the talk,
you'll know where to go. Before we start talking
about, you know, getting into to some of the
meat, I want to give you a little history
how we got here. So, Google has a lot of APIs,
all right. I think close to a hundred APIs
and we've been at this for awhile building
APIs. Last year at I/O, we introduced some
new API infrastructure that we've been building
and that allowed us to build APIs easier and
also to build client libraries easier. The
reason we did that is because at Google scale,
we have, you know, an Mxówhat's called an
MxN problem, right? We have close to 100 APIs.
We also have at least five languages that
we want to support on a regular basis. So,
every time we add either another language
or another API, that's a lot of updates. That
MxN, you know, 100 APIs by five languages,
that's 500 points you got to fill in; that
doesn't really scale very well. And so we
came up with this new API infrastructure that,
again, we introduced that I/O last year that
helps us. It builds, gives us some common
information on the backend and some common
information on the client side that makes
it easier to build libraries or to add a new
API to an existing library. So part of that
is discovery and that discovery document is
a machine readable representation of what
an API looks like, all right? This is useful
because it's useful for clients, if you're
running a client library you can consume that
format and build the client using just the
data there. Or it's useful for building tools.
I'm going to show you a few tools that are
built on top of Discovery. We use it ourselves.
If you want--I'm not going to actually going
to go into the format or anything like that.
If you're interested in it, we have a section
Building Custom Client Libraries for Google
APIs at Google I/O proper. That would be going
at a very great detail. So, like I said, we
support, you know, libraries in different
languages. Okay, but we have lots of APIs.
These are the APIs that we have today that
are built on top of that new API infrastructure.
Now you're at Google I/O, who knows during
an I/O this list may actually get longer.
We won't go into that now. Look at these APIs.
So we've got Buzz, right, if you use Buzz,
there's an API for Buzz. So if you want to
programmatically add things to your activity
stream, add comments, things like that, that's
what that's for. Latitude API, that's our
location API, you know where your phone. Search
API for shopping, just like it says, it allows
you to programmatically look to the product
search. Google URL Shortener, this is actually
the one we're going to focus on for this talk
to kind of get our feet wet looking at all
the various APIs. It's a good API because
it's small. It's easy to understand but it
covers, you know, some of the bases that we
want to talk about. So, it's good in that
respect. Google Custom Search lets you set
up a search engine just for your narrow slice
of the Internet that you want to search. Moderator
API is an API for the moderator that we introduced--I
think it was last year. Moderator allows you
to--you know, people ask questions. Prediction
API, probably one of my favorite APIs allows
you to take large gobs of data and apply machine
learning to them. And--so, you're going to
apply machine learning to that data and then
go back and use the prediction API a second
time to say, "Okay, I've got this one sample,
what do you predict is, you know, going to
be? What's going to happen with that data?"
So, that's really cool. And diacrities allows
you to pass in some foreign languages. A non
English languages and get diacritical marks
for them on how to pronounce them. So, and
like I said, possibly many more coming soon.
So, let's look at Google URL Shortener. If
you haven't seen this before, this is a product
from Google, goo.gl. So, let's go there and
look at goo.gl. And it's a shortener service.
You type in your long URL and it gives you
a shortened version of that, http://www.google.com/IO,
that's actually not a terribly long URL but
I can shorten that and now I get this shortened
URL over here. Useful for when you're using
services that restrict the number of characters
you're going to be, you know, you're allowed
to type. If you're limited to, say, 140 characters,
text messages or if it's up on a slide at
a presentation and people need to type it
in by hand. All useful things for reasons
you would want to shorten a URI. So this is
the product. The cool part is, it does more
than just shortening. What I can do is I can
actually get analytics based on the following
of those URIs. So here's the analytics page.
Here's a URL that was shortened. The long
URL is just Google.com. The shortened URL
is the FPS--capital S and you can see how
many people have clicked through or used that
shortened URL to go to the long URL over time.
There's that the referrers where that actually
occurred. You get to know the countries, the
browsers, the platforms, like that. So, nice,
useful information you can get. Those analytics
over different time ranges, weeks, months,
all time. So, that's a useful service but
as a software developer it's not a too useful
service to you, right? You may want to add
a shortening service to your product, right?
That's where it comes in useful, right? So
then we introduced the Google URL Shortener
API. This is an API to do that same exact
service on Google URL Shortener. So, here
is the link to the documentation. And here's
a shortened link to the documentation. It's
all right there. Before we go diving into
that documentation though, I want to take
a little detour into REST. So, all of the
APIs that we've introduced are RESTful. Now,
in short, you know, what does REST mean? It
means we're using http and we're using it
in a nice way, right? We're using it, you
know, we're using a lot of the capabilities
of http and--so, REST. Let's do a brief introduction
to that. Once we get that brief introduction
down that will help us understand kind of,
the documentation. It will give us a framework
for understanding the documentation for all
these APIs. So, one of the common idioms in
REST is this idea of a collection, right?
It's a collection. It's a bag. It's a set.
It's a grouping of similar things, right?
And lots of things in the world fall into
this idea of collections. Here, a collection--everything
in that collection is called a resource, right?
Resources have URIs. So there's URI, they
live out on the web, there's URI for them.
If I, you know, send an http get to that URI,
I'll get back a representation of whatever
that resource is. So, one collection could
be my buzz activities, all right? Each activity
in my--each activity in that activity stream
has a URI. I do a get on it and in this case
I get back Jason, Jason representation of
what that is. Which is nice, easy, I can manipulate
that programmatically. It could be contacts
in a contact list. It could be shortened URLs,
right? That collection could be all the URLs
I've ever shortened. But the important point
is they have URIs you call "get" on them,
you get back a representation. Now, I could
take that representation, JSON, modify it
in some way, whatever is legal for the API.
Modify it, update it, change something about
it and call "put" or HTTP PUT with that JSON
right back to that same exact URI. That updates
it within the collection. So it's a very simple
yin-yang thing there. I get it, modify it,
put it, it's always back to that same URI.
If I want to remove something from the collection
with something appropriate, I'll call delete
and that removes it from my activity stream.
Or I can post. I'd take some of that JSON
representation of what the resource is, I
post it to the collection and that's it. [INDISTINCT]I
can call "get" on that and that returns me
a list of all the things that are in that
collection. So, this is really simple. Like
I said, it's a bag. It's a group of stuff
and there's some rules for how to manipulate
it. In this case, all those rules go by what
is available on HTTP. So, now we can start
diving in to the Google URL Shortener API.
And this is why I wanted to take that little
detour into REST because you could now see
the Google URL Shortener is broken up into
one collection, right? There's our thing.
There's a URL collection. It's just a bag
of collections. And here's those methods that
we talked about. I can insert a long URL into
that collection. When I insert that long URL
that creates its shortened equivalent. I can
get, if I know a shortened URL, I can call
HTTP GET on it and I can get the long URL
of it. And finally list, I can get a list
of all my shortened URLs out of that collection.
So, obviously this is a very small API, right?
If you look at Buzz, there's going to be lots
of collections in there. That is why I like
the Shortener API because it's small but it
gets to the point that there's these collections
and this is how you manipulate it. So, we
can now go look at the documentation for the
Google URL Shortener API. I can look at the
docs and I can go here and look at the reference
guide. And you'll now see, let me blow this
up so that it's actually visible on the screen,
right? There's that what I told you about
before. There--it's a collection. Insert,
get and list. And finally, URL resource. This
is going to be, what is that presentation?
What's that thing I'm sending across the wire
that represents a shortened URL? A member
of that collection. So, in this case, it's
a shortened URL. The long URL is obviously
going to have to be in there. The status when
it was created, analyticsID is going to be
the shortened URL. And we'll actually see
this. We'll play around with this a little
more. So, down here, it's going to tell you
what all the different properties are on that
object that goes back and forth. So, all right.
So, that documentation describes, right, what
the representations are, what the URIs that
you're going to be getting to and from and
the methods that get applied and the description
of that. So, at this point we can send you
off into the woods, right? Take your favorite
programming language or HTTP library and your
JSON--your favorite JSON library and go to
town. And you could do that, right? But we
have more help available to get you going
and up to speed on that. So, but like I said,
we have client libraries and we'll go through
the list of client libraries yourself. We'll
go to the list of client libraries later.
But if you're using a programming language
that we aren't covering right now, you may
have to give that HTTP client library and
JSON library. And start building a client
library. And if you are, you might want to
attend that "Building Custom Client Library"
section I talked about at I/O. I believe that
someone's [INDISTINCT]. Let's go back. So--but
we have help. One of the bits of help is APIs
explorer. APIs explorer is built on top of
that discovery document. So, here, code.google.com/apis/explorer.
This is a tool for helping you navigate around
and learn about APIs. It's a web based application.
It has all the APIs that are build on this
API infrastructure on it and allows you to
actually make live requests and manipulate
these APIs yourself. So, you can look down
this list--this is the list I showed you before:
buzz, customsearch, diacritize, moderator,
prediction, shopping, site verification, looks
like this--are there anyone in there? Okay,
urlshortener. There's our urlshortener, V-1
is the version--there's right now only one
version of the urlshortener API. If there
is another one, you'd had multiples to choose
from and here's those methods that we talked
about on that collection. Get, insert and
list. So, I can actually start playing with
this URL API live and I'm going to have actually
shrink this down a bit so I can get in here.
SO, on get, I have two parameters over here.
I have the short URL and I have the projection,
right? Analytics_clicks and analytics_topstrings
and full. So let's go back look actually at
the reference documentation for that, so we
can line these two things up. So I have url.get,
alright. Url.get method--this like, should
be able to expand. Get back to here. All right,
can you see that? Okay. So, method requires
two query parameters, your API key--we're
not going to talk about that right now. It
also understands the optional query parameter,
the projection. And so, remember I pointed
to you to that resource that had all that
information about that URI was, the shortened
URI. You can actually get subsets of that
information. You may not need it all. So,
there's some abilities to get shortened bits
of it. So, let's go back to APIs explorer.
So, in order to do this, the first thing I
need is the short URL. So, http://u.gl/fbsS,
that is our shortened URL that we're looking
at earlier and I'm just going to execute this
because that's my only required field. And
I execute it. And so now you see what happened,
and did I get on https:googleapi/urlshortener/v1
pass in the short URL and what is it do? It
gives me back JSON. It tells me what kind
it is, obviously it's a URL shortener resource
but there's the short URL and there's the
long version. Obviously, shortening google.com
is not a terribly good use of the service
but you get the idea and the status is okay.
Now, I can go back up and say what projection
I want. Do I want the clicks? Do I want the
top string or do I want full? I'm going to
get full. I'd run rerun, that same exact query.
This is running live. It's going through my
browser but it is still using that same API
and now I get to look at what the response
would be if I wanted a full projection. So,
I've got my status, when I created it and
the analytics for all time. How many times
was that expanded, the counts, all of that
information that you saw in that web interface
that was available in the product, is available
here through this search, through this API.
So, all the parts of the API. So this is an
important part of learning to, you know, in
using these APIs. First, go check out the
documentation. Second, play around it with
the APIs explorer and make sure it can do
what you want it to do and then, as we'll
get to in a bit, actually start, you know,
picking a client library and manipulating
it that way. So there is get, here's insert.
I want to add a request. So insert doesn't
take any parameters, right? But I have to
give it a JSON body to send over. So I'm going
to go back over here and look at the insert.
I'm going to post and its going to give me
an example of what the JSON should look like
that I'm going to be posting to there. So,
I'll copy that and what's my long URL? http://google.com/il.
All right. There's my body, I execute that,
and now that's what happened, right? So I
post it to that URI. I posted this content
and it sends me backó-here's my URL that
I shortened for you. So, there's the long
URL and there's the shortened version of it.
So I can manipulate all these APIs. Finally,
last step, list. So I can get a list and this
doesn't have any required parameters. I can
get a list of all the APIs that I've created,
shortened URLs that I've created. All right,
this failed. I wanted that to. So, this method
requires you to be authenticated. So if we
go back and look at this reference, back at
the top, you'll notice this column "access
authenticated" over here. This is user data.
All right. All the other stuffs is kind of
public information, right? There's a shortened
URL. It's been shortened. There's a short
version and a long version. This though, list
is my shortened URLs, the ones that I've created.
So that being user specific data, I've got
to log in to get that. Now, that is done using
OOF2. Here, on the API, I'm going to say switch
to private access on the API's explorer and
it says I want to manipulate. This application
which is API's explorer is requesting permission
to manage my short URLs. Yes?
>> Let me know all the analytics in public
Google.
>> GREGORIO: Yes, Google URL short term. So,
yes, you saw me full up those analytics that
the FSSFB that goes to google.com, I didn't
create that one. So, and we'll go through
and see that it isn't there. See? All the
analytics are there but you can't tie it to
the person who actually created that short
URL. So, this flow here is an OOF flow. All
right. It's very important that you'll notice
what isn't happening. What isn't happening
is that the APIs explorer is not asking me
for my name and password, right? It's a very
important thing that we're trying to get away
from. You don't want to get your users in
the habit of entering their name and password
and things. So one of the things we're stressing
is OOF2 in this case, for all these APIs.
OOF is a system that allows you to have a
person give permission for an app; either
desktop app, mobile app, or a web app; access
to an API without them having to type their
name and password into that application. And
that's what's happening here. The APIs explorer
is asking me for permission to say that it
can manipulate my shortened URLs. So, we're
going to go into this a little bit more but
there are other talks if you're interested
to OOF2, I'll get to those on the slides,
there are other talks that go into more detail
on OOF2. So I'm going to say yes. I'm going
to give you access on that re-run, that request.
Now that API explorer is authorized and now
you can see the shortened list, right? And
there's the one, there's the one I--yes, that's
the one I just created right now. All right?
There's the shortened version, the long version,
it's okay and that's when I created it. So
that is APIs explorer. So, there was this
idea though that I had to log in. That's APIs
explorer. APIs Console. So OOF, I'm not going
to go into a whole lot of detail into OOF
but there's a little bit you need to know.
So, that leads us now into the next tool that
we have which is APIs Console. If--okay, yes.
Here's also--like I said I'm going to go into
a little bit of OOF. If you want to learn
more about OOF right now, there's the, unfortunately,
unshortened link to the OOF2 documentation.
There's also two other talks coming off at
IO. There's the 'Life of a Google API Developer'
and there's 'Client Log-in Fail', okay? Client
Log-in Fail--client log is actually a log-in
system that requires end users to put in their
user's name and password. As you can see,
we're trying to lead you away from that. So,
those are two of the talks you might want
to check out. So, the APIs Console. So, you've
looked the documentation, you see an API that's
going to work for you. You played around with
it in the APIs explorer, it does what you
want it to do, you've got it worked in, you're
pretty happy. Okay. Now you're going to start
building an application. For you to build
an application, first stop is going to be
the APIs Console. All right? This is where
we're going to set up a correspondence between
you, the person and the application you're
building. So, I'm going to come in to, that's
API/console. I'm going to come in here and
I'm just going to create a new project. So,
this is going to be my BootCamp Project. BootCamp,
example. I create that project and now you'll
see here, I have the list of all the API's
that are available to me to use in that application.
And right now, they're all off. Right? So,
if I'm going to build a URL Shortener, one,
I'm going to have to turn that on. Now, I
may or may not have to read the terms of service.
It actually did not pop up in this case because
I've actually already read it. But as you
turn on these API's, you probably have to
read the terms of service and agree to them.
That, "Yes, I'm building an app. I know what
the terms of service are for that API." I'm
going to turn that on. You will see that I
have a courtesy limit of 1,000,000 queries
per day. Okay? I think for my sample, almost
set, I don't think I'll run out of that.
We will also see though, that for some APIs,
like prediction, there is pricing. The courtesy
limit is 100 queries a day. You might very
well run out of that. Pricing is you can buy
more quota for that. And so, for each one
of those, there is going to be prices associated
with those. Okay. So this is theóyou'll notice
like I said, Google has about a 100 APIs or
so. This is not 100. [INDISTINCT] but it's
not. The other APIs of the Google Data APIs
and they currently do not show up in here.
So, we're working on getting APIs move it
over unto the new console and to the new API
infrastructure. So...
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> I am scanning the back row looking for
a product manager and are they different for
apps? I don't believe they're different for
apps. Okay. The question was, "Are the courtesy
limits are different if you're using this
against an apps--Google apps domain?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> Okay. And the answer is a [INDISTINCT]
limits are the same. Good question there.
I thought of that. Okay. So, I'm going to
come in and I'm going to create a console
here for that--an application. I turned on
just the APIs I want. All right? That's because
I'm going to then go out and create--you know,
I could go here. I could go "Whoo." I'm going
to go wild and then I turn on all the APIs
for this, right? Besides, accepting a lot
of terms and service there's no real downside
to that. You don't want to do that though
because you're going to be setting up a lot
of credentials for your application. And if
you somehow lose those credentials, those
credentials are then good for every API you've
turned on in here, right? So, you want to
actually pick as an arrow set as possible,
just for the sake of safety. So, if I have
billing that I need to turn on, say for the
prediction API; you would come down here.
Use your Google Checkout. Turn on billing,
then we go down to API access. So, in order
to use OOF from within your application, you're
going to need to create OOF client IDs for
that. So I come in here and I'm going to say,
"This is my BootCamp Sample Application."
Remember when I authorized the APIs Explorer;
up at the top I said Goggle APIs Explorer
wants access to, whatever you're getting access
to, that's where this comes in. All right?
You're going to get this--your users are going
to get a screen like that, it's going to go,
you know, "My app, blah, blah, blah." This
is where you get to save that--what that shows
up there. You can also actually put a product
logo up there. So people can be assured, "Yes.
I'm really, you know, authorizing access to
what I think I'm authorizing access to." Next
step in creating those OOF credentials are
creating the application type; either to web
application or it's an installed application.
In this case we'll just go with installed
application. And there's going to be some
differences, like I said, that will be covered
in the OOF tube talks later. Well, I create
my client ID. The only thing you really need
to know about this is that I've got a client
ID and a client secret. And those need to
be cut and paste and put over into your application
using the OOF two client libraries for what
you're working with. That says then--when
a person goes to authorize into that application,
it allowed pop up on the screen. They don't
have to enter name or password and says, "This
application," which is now tied to you because
you logged in to this console, "this application,
wants access to your data." So you're setting-up
that trust there, so. If--though you have
an API, say you were just building an app
that unshortened URLs. Remember that didn't
require authentication, right? That did not
require authenticated access. It wasn't accessing
user data. If that's the case, then you don't
need to use the--you don't need to use OOFF
but you're still going to need to use the
API key. And all the client libraries have
this as an--as available and you saw that
actually in the documentation, right? So,
when I go back to this reference documentation
you'll see this key here, has this parameter.
That's what this is. This is the simple API
access. So, you can't use this to access protected
user data but if you're accessing an API that
doesn't need it, like the URL shortened of
Get, then you can just use this. The user
then won't be thrown through that OOFF2 flow,
it'll just work. The nice part about this
though is you then get lots of nice statistics,
whether you use OOFF2 or the API access. That
APIs--you're used to that APIs tied to you
and we can now keep track of statistics, so
you can get to know, you know, figure out
how much your API is actually used. So, that's
the API access that gives me my credentials
that I'm going to put into my application
and finally team. Once you've created this
project you can start adding other people
into this. So it's tied to more than one person.
So, that's the developer console. Like I said,
if you're interested in OOFF2 and how these
pieces tie together, there is two more talks
coming up that'll go into this in much more
detail. Finally libraries, okay, like I said,
we're not going to, you know, throw you off
into the woods with just http and JSON. So,
we have client libraries available. We have
PYTHON and JAVA. Those libraries are in Beta.
Beta for Google means that they are, obviously,
actively developed but at this point we're
down to bug fixing and adding new features.
We don't expect major changes to the interfaces
for these APIs. We really want you to start
building on top of these libraries. Alpha
means actively under construction. We'd like
you to use them but they're actively in the
construction. Stuff will break. Stuff will
break in--you know backward incompatible.
We're experimenting, we're iterating on these
systems and they're under development. So,
for Alpha, we have PHP, Ruby and DotNet libraries
and like I said, for the Beta versions we
have PYTHON and JAVA. Above and beyond those
client libraries, we have specific documentations.
So actually, let me just follow through and
look at the PYTHON client library. So here's
the documentation for it. You go to there,
you'll be landed on it--their--obviously hosted
on code.google.com. You've got documentation
for it. Each one of these client libraries
will have a getting started guide. This will
walk you through how--what does the API look
like? How was it used? How do you install
it? Plenty of documentation there. So you
can see here on the side the different platforms
it works on, lots of OOFF2 documentation,
advanced information on debugging, optimizing,
thread safety, things like that. So--and these
are open source projects. You find a bug;
you can just report it in the Issue tracker.
That would be great. If you find a bug and
know how to fix it, you can contribute to
Patch. That would be even better. But they're
all open source, so you can see how they work.
Download it, fiddle with it, get it to work
for you. So, that's the Python client library.
Like I said, all of the client libraries are
going to have the same structure, developers
guide, etc. Also, we start to see with this
is going to be more documentation. So, reference
documentation here is--here is basically the
core of the library--for the Python library.
Now, unless you program in Python, this looks
ugly. If you program on Python, it looks ugly
too but you understand it, okay? So, this
is the standard the way of documenting Python
client libraries. JAVA--the JAVA client library,
no surprise to those JAVA doc. So, but not
only that there is documentation for the individual
s. So, this is going to be what those API
surfaces look like in Python for particular
API. So, for example, urlshortener. Remember,
we said it was a collection, right? It was
a collection. There's that URL collection.
And here's those three methods associated
with that: get, insert and list. And you can
see how this becomes if, you know, reading
the documentation. If I wanted to do a get
on the urlshortener, my arguments are the
projection which is a string and has these
values. Remember when I did it in the APIs
explorer, I used full--that got me my full
analytics. And then I also have to pass in
as a parameter the shorturl. Insert, there's
the body I have to insert. We did that. And
then list. And then I could also--the list
actually took a projection which we didn't
put in either. So, this URL--remember we started
back with, it was that RESTful interface.
It was this idea of collections. That whole
collection idiom boils down into the API itself.
And now, as you can see, it's the same exact
surface in the generated Python client library.
We'd covered PyDoc. We covered PyDoc for API.
Obviously, like I said, there's Java Doc for
the Java client library. It should be familiar
to you if you are a Java programmer. One of
the other tools is Google Plug-in for Eclipse.
So, this is a plug-in that just recently added
APIs support into it. So, it's a plug-in for
Eclipse if Eclipse is your editor. And this
will allow you easier access into these APIs.
And actually going to demo this in just a
second. Apparently, I'm going to demo it right
now, okay. So, let's fire-up Eclipse. So,
here's where I defy all common sense into
a live demo and a live demo on Eclipse, nonetheless.
Where am I? Okay. So, all right. So, Google
Plug-in for Eclipse is a plug-in originally
launched with this idea that you can create--that
is not the one I wanted. It's not the Eclipse
I was looking for. So, all right. While we're
waiting for Eclipse to launch, let's do Python.
Okay. So, we said--this is what Python is
good for, for filling in the time. So, we
went and we wanted to do the urlshortener,
right? And this is the documentation for the
urlshortener. We're going to presume Python.
So, we will come in here. And in Python, I
want to import--[INDISTINCT] that even more.
Edit preferences, fonts and colors. Sorry
about this, should have been bigger to begin
with. Can you read that apiclient.discovery--no,
that's from--import build? Okay. So, I want
to create a service interface, build. Now,
which API do I want to interact with? It's
urlshortener. The name and the version need
to be passed in. Its urlshortener and ver--v1--shortener
and v1. That gives me that service. Now, if
I go and look in here--look at the surface.
One collection, that's URL. So, service.url.
And what are the methods that are available
on that collection? Get, insert and list.
So, I'm going to do get. So, .get and where
do I pass it? Shorturl is required. That's
the only thing I need. So, shorturl="http://goo.gl/fbsS").execute()
I need a little more caffeine, all right.
And, I will now save this file, save as, save
it to my desktop as "shorten2.py". I'm now
going to go to my desktop. There is "shorten2.py."
No slight of hand. I really just did type
that, python shorten2.py, I run it and there
it is. It's shorten.uri. You can see here
a status of okay, my shortened work. There's
my ID of the shortened one that I had and
a long URL that I just unwrapped that from.
So it's a very simple service. So, if we are
now lucky, eclipse has finished loading. I'm
going to close that project. So, I'm going
to come in here and create a new web application
project. So this is what Google plug-in for
eclipse initially launched with. It's got
support for Google web tool kit and Google
app [INDISTINCT]. So it's for making Java
applications with those. To keep things simple,
I'm going to turn off Google web tool kit
for this example but I'm going to create an
app engine example. My project name is sample3
com.google.sample3. So, this goes through,
blast out all the code I need in Java. So
here's my source, comgoogle sample3. There's
my code. It just, you know, creates my little
servelet which will run on app engine, right?
And it runs text plane. This is HelloWorld.
So if I run that--now obviously this is an
app engine talk but we'll see in a second
where this is going, local host 8888, there's
my sample free servelet and this is HelloWorld.
Very tiny letters. [INDISTINCT] that in. This
is HelloWorld. Okay. Right. So, that's good.
But I said we had help for APIs. Import, and
so add Google API. And this structure should
look fairly simple to you. Code search, calendar,
books, buzz, moderator, spreadsheets, URL
shortener. Here's your API. So, this will
add in support for the URL shortener API in
Java into this project. So, I'm going to stop
running because I've made that mistake before.
You will now notice over here in the left
hand side, Google URL shortener. Here is the
base API client library which is that and
then there is this library that's been added
in which has very specific code to the URL
shortener API. I may expand that out there
a little bit. Okay. There's an http client
class. That's good. We're making request.
There's a URL shortener class. That's good.
We're using URL shortener. And there is the
model classes down here. So now we can start
using that API and all the goodness of Eclipse.
So, I want to import URL shortener, that's
the correct one equals new URL shortener.
Where are the parameters I am missing? My
string, my transport and my factory. So this
is going to be my BootCamp sample. I need
a new net http transport. And a new Jackson
factory. Those are for http and JSON. All
right. We're currently very happy. Let's expand
this up so that we can actually see the whole
code. So, now I need to use this service later.
So I'm going to say S dot--hey, there's URL.
Right? Remember? Same idiom. There's the collection.
Put on the collection, I want to do a Get.
What do I want to get? Well, that's the shortened
URL, right, http://google.gl/fesS and now
dream about that URL and I call--opps. Execute
on that. That should give me back a URL and
that URL, I need to import from a model. And
so, instead of here, down here, I'm going
to print out URL dot--long URL. So same thing
we've known +the whole time. Right? So, again
come in idioms, we've got this API, it's a
collection we call "get", but you notice now
I've got all the nice pieces of auto-complete.
And now, I'm going to run my project again
and once we're running--blam, there's our
long URL. So, cool. So, like I said at the
beginning of the talk, here's that Python
code that we just did. Don't expect you to
understand every bit of it but I hope by now,
by the end of the talk, you now know where
to go to get the information. All right? We
know that this is a Python client library,
I gave you the link to that, Google API Python
client. We know it's the URL shortener, API.
You know where to go for the docs for that.
If we need a developer key, we know where
to go for that, that's the APIs console. We
want to know what the actual calls are per
an API, that's API Python client doc, that's
the API specific documentation for Python.
And finally, if I want to exercise and play
around with this, that's the APIs explorer.
So we covered a lot--there's a lot of APIs
out there. We're introducing more all the
time. You can see all the other APIs. So like
I said, like the question came out before,
these are the APIs that we're talking about
right now that are built on top of that new
infrastructure. We still have lots of other
APIs on the older infrastructure, the Google
Data APIs. You want to see all the APIs we
have available, code.google.com/more. If you
like this section and want to get a little
more hands-on with it. If you wanted to, you
know, go to API explorer hands-on. Get some
hands-on with some Python Code. We have a
lab this afternoon, 1:45 to 3:45 in Robertson
2, "Hands on with Google APIs" lab. Like I
said before, we're just going to basically
go through this presentation but in a lot
more detail, hands-on at every step, get into
some code at the end. And finally, between
now and the hands-on on in the lab, actually
for the rest of the day, folks from the APIs
team are going to be available in office hours.
So here, this link should bring you to your
pre-requisites. If you are interested in the
lab, you should've get an email that's said,
"Here's the pre-reqs to install," if you don't
have those installed or you need help in installing
those, come to office hours, we'll give you
a hand. Or if you just have questions on APIs,
again, come to office hours. That's it. Thanks.
We got about ten minutes for questions.
>> I have a question though, the Java clients
libraries, they don't click on Android [INDISTINCT]
or...
>> GREGORIO: So the question was, so the question
was, "Are the Java client libraries optimized
for Android?" Yes, the Java client libraries
use a tool which escapes me now but that restricts
them down so that they'd--yes, they do run
on Android.
>> So totally [INDISTINCT]
>> GREGORIO: Yes.
>> Excuse me sir, perhaps the web search that
you're engaged on, do any of them that calls
at least they have, I believe you can call
back "background review" like JSON P calls
you.
>> GREGORIO: So the question was, can we do
call backs. JSON P call backs for these APIs
and the answer is yes. They do accept that
call back parameter.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> GREGORIO: Yes, the post is to add a new
one and there's a PUT to update. So, you actually
don't see that in the URL shortened API but
you go to some of the other APIs. For example,
the buzz has a PUT to update an activity,
for example.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> GREGORIO: Right. Yes?
>> Is there like data [INDISTINCT] from [INDISTINCT]
of the data which are [INDISTINCT] about the
data about that has been filed set and that
probably affects us--you [INDISTINCT]
>> GREGORIO: Okay. So the question was, "Can
I restrict what comes back through that?"
Yes. What we saw in the URL shortener, there's
this idea of a projection to restrict the
set of the data that comes back per entry.
Lots of other APIs also support query parameters.
So instead of getting everything that is in
the collection, you can get just the things
that match that query. There is also an idea
of pagination, so you can set max results,
you know, only return 25 and there's a way
to paginate and say get the next page of results.
So, does that? Okay. All right, any other
questions? All right, thank you very much.
Looking forward to see in office hours and
at the lab.